well you know the consumer electronics
show it's supposed to be here in las
vegas right now with hundreds of
thousands of people but
it is virtual this year ces has to go
online because of the pandemic but that
doesn't mean
we can't talk about gadgets and here to
talk about some of the things on display
this year danielle casino joining us
live to talk about what is
going to be in our future in the present
in the future danielle good morning to
you
good morning we miss you all in vegas
this week
all right so let's talk about some of
the things on the horizon here tech wise
that we're going to be seeing today
yeah so obviously the pandemic impacted
how
ces is showing up this week digitally
all in line kind of a reimagined
experience
and that impact is showing up in the
tech we're seeing and the announcements
also digital health has been a growing
part of the show over the past few years
and this year it's
it's really front and center we've seen
robots from samsung and lg
that focus on disinfection and
sanitization
and home robots and i have a few
products here
that are related as well like this
airpoint
device that you can use your own device
so you don't have to touch others to
touchlessly navigate whether you're a
teacher
or a presenter and having that ability
to
have your own device so we're seeing a
lot of touchless
devices and technology in that area
and then this device is the bio button
this small flexible
wearable that uh sticks on your left
chest
like a sticker was created with covet in
mind from biointelligence intellisense
and this has a continuous respiratory
rate
heart rate and temperature monitoring so
you can
have an early onset diagnosis
or um ability to identify those
um covid symptoms early so
it seems like wearable technology in
addition to the idea
of health it's kind of a quick pivot to
some extent i would imagine for the tech
industry
uh we yesterday we saw some tvs and
computer screens but
i imagine in the tech industry there's
been a big effort to sort of pivot
towards health because there's so much
focus on it now during the pandemic
right it really accelerated a lot of the
progress that was happening towards
things like telehealth and remote
patient monitoring this year
so while you may have been forced to do
more
regular checkups via computer or
telehealth with your doctor
there's also been a surge for those home
options also like this one from
omron healthcare which is a whole kit i
just have the blood pressure monitor
here
but this you have the ability to update
on
um chronic conditions like hypertension
be able to communicate those results
with your doctor
virtually so you don't have to come in
unless necessary and it sort of
add on to that patient care experience
and that trend has been accelerated with
the inability to
or disinterest in in going into the
doctor's office this year
and last year so i'm wondering how soon
we
we talk about how ces is always you know
the the future
how long before maybe the things you
have there are the present things that
we could see in
the public you know within the next
couple months or maybe the next year
yeah these i've showed are are announced
this week and
and will be available now or coming up
soon
uh there's also you know part of the
beauty of ces is sort of those future
concepts that
may or may not come to fruition but
paint us a picture of the future
i'm thinking of in the car space
beautifully designed screens
and in-car experience from mercedes
the tvs are getting bigger and better
and really large like 100 plus screens
are becoming available
so that will um you know start to
trickle down to
to the consumer um awareness soon
very cool we're all looking forward to
the future danielle thank you very much
for coming in we can't wait to see you
back in las vegas next year
appreciate the time